gamespot here at Gamescom 2014 I'm
delighted to be joined by the 11-time
tag team champion only man in the
history of wrestling to have the ECW www
en World Heavyweight Championship the
one and only Big Show sir are worried I
need to the air ducts not it's all good
yeah you've had a lot of titles that
will be your long and storied wrestling
career but surely none is more important
than brand ambassador for this fantastic
game but we have 18kt well you're good
you do this for a living I don't oh you
should that's a great I'm not telling
anything that's one thing you learn
working for definitely you don't tell
Vince anything I want to know what the
picture of things about this latest a
new chapter for the series what's you
know I'm a gamer okay first of all I'm
excited about this game because the work
in the effort the 2k put into this game
is unbelievable you are gonna really be
flabbergasted over the life like realism
of the way this game feels when you see
gold dust walk down the ramp it looks
like Rovers you see gold dust lock up
into a wrist lock turning into a
hammerlock floated over to headlock and
a headlock takeover it looks like gold
dust executing from the speed the way
the body moves his hips his feet plant
you see Randy Orton walk down the ramp
you see Randy's quads his biceps the
cheekbones is the way his beards cut
even the way he moves in the ring you
know how Randy has his own stuff each
individual superstar moves differently
and it has their own little nuance it's
unbelievable the work they put into this
if I made my own character with my bicep
show as well it's like a normal way
smaller yeah thanks very much you're
welcome you've had obviously thousands
of their matches on the entire career if
you can make one match in
we 2k15 and change it probably uh I
change it ah change it well first of all
I would be undefeated WrestleMania I
never would've lost i would have beat
ocupado let it be buoyed mayweather
money Mayweather yeah down the list yeah
everybody how to change it actually I've
been undefeated rest of me if I could
change it well I think I have the
reverse Undertaker record right so I
think I'm like senior string warden is
one thing I'm like wanted 1201 in 13th
but hey I've been in 14 them so there
you go two weeks time Seattle packs one
rumbles hop at all yeah that's exciting
right you think summer slams big so who
do you thinks gonna win you got doc we
got Dan Reicher we got ox Navarro who's
your pick for the rumble this year dr.
trucks it really [ __ ] come on he's a
doctor and he's a track suit what's
better here first folks dr. tracksuit
better wind dr track suit or I'm pulling
your medical license
well we don't know i'll ask a question
and Marion what's the girls over
tracksuit dr. tracksuit dr. trust ya
don't know